boys you got a little song for us today  right i think we're going to play yeah a  couple of right right oh good or  whatever whatever you guys want now do  you do long train running or yeah you  want to try it or or are you i i don't  know if you guys are up i would like to  hear it sure honestly  yeah we actually right before we walked  in somebody was like i think you guys  might do more than a couple songs we're  like well we should work on laundry and  running so we had to print out the  lyrics oh good remember hanson uh here's  celebrating your new album  by playing songs from the 60s why not  the 70s seventies  [Music]  [Music]  from here  [Music]  [Applause]  won't be coming back  where would you be now  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  where would you be  [Music]  without  now  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  where would you be now  [Applause]  with that love  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  nice job  you